I'm like finger banging this disc
cushion yes there's like a thing in the
middle that's why we put it there just
for you yeah I'm like finger banging
finger blasting it YouTube is just a
hobby it's not i'm not serious about
whatsoever unlike first and foremost an
actor and you know i'm friends with some
you to people like keV keV Jumba and and
Ryan Kevin I've known for like six years
obviously since I met him along like
before that when he was like a minor hmm
now he's like 22 I think 23 22 23 Ryan I
met through keV so those guys are my
homie so they kind of just convinced me
to start YouTube but it's definitely on
a priority in my life that's for sure
that's not my career like digital media
is just like a plus my feet are fully in
you know traditional media you know like
but in terms of like you know digital
media I think it's important i think
it's that's the direction it's going I
don't think you can replace the
experience of being in a theater and
that experience of going out and having
dinner and like going to the movies
getting popcorn sitting an audience with
other people I don't know if that will
go away any time soon so I think it'd
just be digital media would just be a
replacement and it'll be more power you
know more accessible because people can
don't have to leave their house but
there's something to be said about like
watching movie on a 30 foot screen I
don't know so I hope it doesn't die and
it doesn't go away
yeah is if you actually can promote it
but also you know like the quality of
work that I put out in YouTube is not
representative of me as an actor it's
just literally just sketches like that I
just think of for me it's just an outlet
for when I'm really bored and want to be
creative to put something out like
without really even having to think
about quality or any of that there's an
interview with Edward Norton he says the
less people know about you the more you
keep them you know magic or whatever
filmmaking so I do think it does sort of
you know kind of destroy that a little
bit you know when people know you too
well then when they see you in a movie
role you know it's not as interesting
surprising actors actresses I would love
to work with Mark Ruffalo I would love
to work with Crispin Glover I would love
to work with Kenley young I would love
to work with sam rockwell Steve's on my
movies called man up it's about a 19
year old kid who gets his Mormon
girlfriend pregnant she doesn't think
he's fit to be a dad so she breaks up
with him and leaves him his parents
found find out so they kick him out of
the house so he's forced to move in with
a stoner best friend who tries to teach
him how to become a man and be a good
dad and his the stoners you know the
stone of friends reasoning is I've had
all the most horrible dads in the world
so I know what not to do so it's just
like it's pretty much Bill and Ted but
like more [ __ ] more dumb and and
mixed with like quirkiness of like kind
of like Wes Anderson it's like very
stylized like we have a very strong
color palette and the backdrop is Hawaii
I shot in Hawaii so the backdrop is
Hawaii a lot of our music is like Lady
late 80s Early 90s inspired like the
composer and everything we actually got
the editor from Bill and Ted's so he
edited it we're in post-production so
we're doing like we were almost picture
locked so we're starting to you know do
sound mixing and hot stuff
I think shooting in Orange County is
better because they're like happy to
have you you know LA as soon as you see
you shooting the ass like where's your
permit but you have to go to LA Film
Office and like that's annoying
everybody was so full dude shooting one
Chinese way better if I could promote
anything i would say shoot in Orange
County support Orange County film hey
what's going on this is justin chon
you're tuned into new media rockstars
com check out my movie 21 and over in
theaters right now